[Musik]
mit erfolg
[Applaus]
114 102
sie will wie sie froh gezeigt groß mit
jetzt ganze hatte über vorbereiten damit
die planen organisieren und da sind wir
froh ist ein moskito mio
der schirmherr guter zeitpunkt kurz
gefühl ok-präsident urs näpflin hat eine
woche vor dem rennen auch bagatell
probleme zu lösen einer hat den funk
vergessen
[Musik]
hast du träumst du selbst auf diese
punkte zu gast
[Gelächter]
der einst frauen z mit dem mit dem
oberst mohammed vor 61 jahren gibt es
einen vorbereitungskurs gemacht in der
katholischen fehler und die franz mit
seiner frau und und daniel am hof mit
seiner frau sieht es mit einem kurzzeit
sie den händen annehmen und eine flasche
schnaps organist hynix wasser weitere
gäste der mannschaftsführersitzung für
die flasche kostet die lauberhorn
abfahrt ist ein mythos der jahr für jahr
neu inszeniert wird aktuell mit einem
budget von acht millionen franken nur
wegen des sports kommen heutzutage kaum
noch jemand sagt nicht fliehen
man muss sie mir bieten spektakel ist
wichtig der sport muss spektakulär sie
der sport braucht sprühendes braucht
schwierige passage die zuschauer muss
sehe vor ort oder im fernsehen wo diese
fahrt verliert oder sie gewinnen aber
das spektakel darf nie auf kosten für
die gesundheit der fahrer gab
sobald das ist gefährlich wird das
erfahren so schwer verletzt dass man das
risiko erhöhte risiko hat der muss das
spectaculum statt und sicherheit von
fahrer muss immer zu jeder zeit der
oberste priorität starken aber zu
risikoklasse complete drumherum alles
ist startet status können
über 60 tv stationen nutzen die bilder
aus wengen für eine live-übertragung
damit alles inklusive hund shop
rechtzeitig fertig wird stehen rund 1800
helfer im einsatz
[Applaus]
auch die schweizer armee schaufelt mit
den organisationen nicht vorstellbar
aber es ist alles gut ist für über mir
kommen das von der schweiz um vor der
schweiz weiter zum canadien corner und
treibt es ein schock
wo im moment noch die armee verträgt
wird die nieren am rennwochenende wies
der eintritt kostet 900 franken pro
person
dem vernehmen nach mit geschnetzeltem
kartoffelstock serviert
man ist halt nicht nur versessen sondern
vor allem auch für die exklusive
aussicht
aber es klingt nicht schlecht glaube ich
[Applaus]
war ein und spektakel
alles inklusive gespürt dass man sich
eigentlich den weg da muss auch und die
abfahrt muss die die basis bleiben aber
wenn man die leute näher bringen kann
von den später kann ich mich promotionen
her und so immer besser
ja das dann können wir nicht ran
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das ist wirklich so die frage ist wird
goalie kam vor rund 30 jahren von luzern
nach wengen und machte sich hier einen
namen aus bei zehn jahre lang wirkte er
im zielschuss und gehörte zum
lauberhornrennen wieder rund schock
[Musik]
ja
[Gelächter]
bruno lemaire und war treffpunkt trainer
und rennfahrer
[Musik]
außerdem kaffee mary und hier zwischen
menschen und zweiter läuft haben werden
natürlich lockt die person nadal jetzt
mit meiner mitarbeiter natürlich wenn
das wetter in diesen studien zeigen auch
bei der erste kontakt herz analytischer
sich berichtete tomba zwischenwände ich
mache ja natürlich
und das war ja für das akw krsko
toppings das café mehr ist inzwischen in
andere hand und auch sonst hat sich
vieles verändert dass ein rennfahrer
zwischen zwei läufen in einer beiz mit
dem personalchef und rotwein trinkt
heute undenkbar
[Musik]
die zeit überdauert hat die geselligkeit
rund ums laboren rennen
[Musik]
ottobrunn juli hat allerdings auch
traurige erinnerungen zb an einen
fatalen sturz im jahr 1991
ja ich bin wieder hungrig sie damals
natürlich noch dauert die tribünen xi
und das auch noch nicht so groß und hat
ihr budget für der sprung von der stasi
und exorbitant laxey und peugeot
schlimmes müssen vermutet
der 20 jährige österreicher gernot
reinstadler startet am 18 januar 1991 zu
einer qualifikations abfahrt und kommt
im ziel nie an
[Musik]
meine damen und einer grippe
sportfreunde wir wollten uns aus wegen
vielleicht haben sie es im verlaufe des
vormittags schon gehört die 61
lauberhorn abfahrt ist abgesagt worden
der 21 jährige tiroler gernot
reinstadler aus herzens im pitztal der
gestern im zielhang schwer gestürzt
waren ist kurz nach mitternacht im
spital von interlaken gestorben am rhein
stadler erinnert eine gedenktafel in
wengen gottes wille kennt kein warum
heißt es da
das ist so bender
ja
zwar kann jeder machen und uns sondern
blöd den umbau passiert wenig
ausschlägen grazia und behörden
die tiroler berge hier lernte gernot
reinstadler skifahren
[Musik]
sein elternhaus steht den herzens im
pitztal
[Musik]
die kommissarinnen es war so wunderschön
wie heute
und dann bin ich noch um 3 uhr unterhalb
30 euro aufgefallen
dann bin ich mit einer frau aufgefahren
von der person und ein verkehrsunfall in
der schweiz hatte er denkt immer wie
schafft es so wie er selber will schafft
es und bin ihr aufgefallen und bin dann
heim und die wusste dass in wengen
was waren dieser quali abfahrt ja und
ich komplette tür rein und telefon
läutet und noch das der trainer apparat
gewesen gleich sagen wir müssen den
schlimmsten den schlimmsten wir müssen
den schlimmsten rechnen und das waren
nachmittag und in der nacht um 1 uhr
wieso dann gestorben
und dann haben wir einen anruf kriegt
also sehr gerne dies gestorben das ist
einfach zu schwer
alles getan aber es war schlimm und dann
haben wir haben wir gewartet und drei
talker weil die es braucht ja fehler
wenn sie über die grenze gehen und alles
aber wir konnten neben den sarg
irgendwie aufmachen oder was weiß
versiegelt war weil diese über die
grenzen geht also sie haben sie gar
nicht haben wir haben keine uns schauen
und das ist das haben wir die erinnerung
gegangen ist weil wir halt
der weg ist wie haben sie abschied
genommen von ihm
gar nicht so könne den verantwortlichen
in wengen hat sie nie einen vorwurf
gemacht
das verhältnis sei sehr gut gewesen sagt
traudel rein stadler
sie habe auch dieses jahr wie immer eine
einladung ans labor von rennen bekommen
und wäre auch gegangen aber die zimmer
die sie an feriengäste vermietet seien
im moment belegt darum brauchen sie hier
jetzt ist so gerne ich hätte schon vor
mir auch in innsbruck 1964 olympiade
dabei aber reserve und durfte im slalom
als vorläuferin fahren 64 600 ja da ist
noch da sie war skirennfahrerin und es
darf mit 77 jahren noch so oft wie
möglich auf der piste heute mit ihrer
tochter und einem urenkel
[Musik]
morgen anfangs nicht habe war ich weiß
es nicht
warum ja ich bin durchs rennen fahren
aber mein vater ist alle drei gefahren
und die mama nicht jedes ski gehen haben
sie halt bekommen und es haben halt das
hat er gerne doch prägt und raul und u7
und vielleicht noch leichter simon
ich habe das übersprungen
[Gelächter]
der achtjährige raul erinnert seine
großmutter an den verstorbenen gern ob
beide rückte draufgänger
[Musik]
nur noch zwei tage bis zur
lauberhorn-abfahrt der ak-präsident ist
im dauereinsatz
nächster programmpunkt ein
radiointerview
ja ich werde libyen an bord ist
das ist alles fix ab und fällt zum
glücklichen jung per karte setzte alles
nachbar und 107 im rennmodus wenn mir
das sagt und jetzt geht es weiter und
heute nächste da hoffen wir dass mir das
nötige glück
wieso die bringen glück nicht vorhabe
[Gelächter]
die software innerhalb der küche gegner
hat der rennzirkus in wengen wohl nur
wenige wenn überhaupt denn irgendwie
gewinnen halle ein bisschen
wertschöpfung ist rund 30 millionen für
die ganze region also es betrifft die
nummer wengen als ort das ist die ganze
region verderben was profitierte
unbezahlbar sie bilden wollte die ganze
welt ohne dass die mir nicht vorstellen
er gehört zu wagen und dann wieder zwei
blieben zukunft
spürt man den duft nicht im fernsehen wo
vor einer woche noch soldaten auskommen
gegessen haben laufen nun die letzten
vorbereitungen für die gäste
[Musik]
am renntag werden häppchen gereicht
während die fahrer auf der piste kopf
und kragen riskieren
das natürlich tranchen mache das selbst
spezielles aber das ist dass man früher
ihre lämmer brot und spiele
das will das volk also dass träume so
zelebriert um das hat sich eigentlich
nicht viel kann bereits ein forum
geschaffen worden
claudia tore werden am schluss mit sagen
wir mal der welterfolg wird aber ich war
die akteure vor jeder bestenfalls einer
dieser gladiatoren stürzen sollte
komturs allensbach zum einsatz der
wengen der dorfarzt ist am
rennwochenende jeweils teil des
rettungsteams
an und für sich und dann können wir
positiv alle dass es dort
sie sind parat machen wir das was noch
ein mentales dem rad von der
infrastruktur her
[Musik]
also es hat ihnen von beginn weg keine
mühe gemacht wie das laub von bäumen zu
schauen sagt ja wenn es gläubiger schaut
ja ein umfang- und da ist auch noch
franzosen stürzt das ganze sowieso aber
es ist gleich ist ja darauf stolz netze
sind matten gewesen
und das war natürlich gleich ist es
waren natürlich okay gab es also für
sicherheits mäßig viel weil man ja haben
sie sich manchmal gefragt warum das
passiert ist am grabstein steht warum ja
gottes willen warum man gerade und mit
dem hammer warum eigentlich
warum können ein sinnvolles ist kann sie
ihre erfahrung warum wir warum er weiß
nicht gottes wille kein warum wir haben
wir am sonntag am abend das gedenkmesse
und gernot ist ja auch das 20
und das macht man nicht jedes jahr
erkranken jedes jahr wird eine
gedenkmesse an gernot macht kriegt ja
heute am friedhof von meistens nur rosen
heuer steckmann sind schnell rein weil
viele schnee herum friedhof ist und
sonst
aber die gedenkmesse de ist dies ist bei
uns einfach der brauch dass jahres messe
das motto dieses jesus jahr macht das
ist es und ist es noch wichtig so ja der
sommer schon aber sie ja auch meine ja
für für alle warum ist das gut für sie
jetzt dass man heute doch dass jetzt der
erste 18
nicht vergessen ist dass er auch für die
einheimischen ist nicht vergessen
ich glaube ja
der glaube hat den stolzen dass es
weitergeht
im himmel irgendwo er gibt wo ja ich
glaub ja nun ist es soweit der tag der
abfahrt
die häppchen auf der terrasse sind
angerichtet
[Musik]
die gladiatoren können kommen
die brot und spiele
ich glaube ja tory d'alema ja gut das
ist ja das geschrieben was ihre musik
mit die sich gezielt trainiert jetzt den
sie am besten platz den es hier
eigentlich dienst am nächsten
die far east in ihr leben und fischer
und eine komfortzone zu da wissen sie
ich war hochwertig war anfang habe ich
schon über das ist das rennen das sind
unterschiedlicher moment denn es gibt
auch risiken das ist auch klar aber ich
wollte das ganze gut organisiert seit
diese risiken am ende man misst ob
jemand gewinnt ist gewinnt jeder mag das
ist auch sport und spitzensportler ist
wichtig nicht nur autosport kuranyi ist
extrem wichtig aber diese verbindung ist
die presse
hugo priol ist im lauberhornrennen treu
geblieben
er genießt es allerdings schon seit
jahren für sich allein
den trubel brauche er nicht mehr es wäre
die aus anders besser oder schlechter
kann man in der soap und eines das
andere chf aus
[Musik]